[Applause]
I've made many mistakes in my life but
that wasn't one of them
oh but it was when you play the game of
Thrones you win you die
there is no middle ground
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones season
a prediction video today I want to talk
about what I think the final scene of
the Game of Thrones series could be I
briefly answered this in a Q&A video
about two months ago but I wanted to
discuss it a little bit more I actually
have a few different ideas for what I
think the very last scene might be
before I go through some of these I have
to preface this by saying there is one
thing you have to keep in mind I have no
idea how the show is going to end all I
can do is hopefully make some educated
guesses I think most of us are expecting
to get a bittersweet ending because
that's what we have been told by george
RR martin and Dan and Dave but it
doesn't mean the very last scene has to
be bittersweet I think we will lose many
characters during the Great War and that
will be better because we have seen some
of these characters come so far and put
everything on the line in hopes of
making Westeros a better place to live
but in the end they may die for this
cause that could be the better part of
the ending but the last scene could be
somewhat sweet the series could end with
the scene that gives us some form of
hope
even if Westeros is in ruins and some of
our favorite characters are dead the
show could at least end with some
promise for the future this is what I'm
trying to consider when predicting what
I think the last scene could be because
I don't think the show is going to end
with something too terrible happening I
think that will happen during the final
battles but not the final scene the
final book in the A Song of Ice and Fire
series is going to be called a dream of
spring but it was going to be called a
time for wolves but george RR martin
changed it to me that does sound like
there will be a glimmer of hope for
whichever characters are left standing
who will take on the responsibility of
restoring in rebuilding the Seven
Kingdoms into a more civilized and
prosperous place to live maybe I am
being too optimistic but that's how I
always felt now let's get into a few
different ideas that I have had for how
I think this series could end just the
final scene though not the entire finale
I am just trying to picture the very
last image before it fades to black in
the credits roll the first option I
could see happening is the destruction
of the Iron Throne the thousand blades
taken from the hands of Aegon's fallen
enemies forged in the fiery breath of
balerion the dread there are a thousand
blades there aren't even 200 I've
counted huh I'm sure you have ugly
everything this has been a very popular
theory for many years now and I do
believe there is a good chance this
could be the very last thing we see over
the course of this series this throne
has been dissemble of power and
corruption we have lost too many beloved
characters due to people fighting over
who has the rightful claim to sit on the
Iron Throne and as of right now there is
no sign of Cersei having any plans of
giving up her seat of power but the
Targaryen will have something to say
about this Daenerys Targaryen currently
wants to break the wheel and Jon Snow
has no desire to sit on the Iron Throne
so I think it's very likely that one of
them could have it destroyed when enough
they finally cast Cersei down out with
the old and in with the new if they
truly want to make a difference and
completely change the way things have
been done for hundreds of years they can
start with destroying the throne and as
it's being broken apart or melted down
by one of the dragons the scene could
fade to black and we would know things
are definitely about to change
another option is the birth of the next
Song of Ice and Fire
a full fitted the right to claim the
soul
it's yours it serve you well and your
children after you
the series could end with Daenerys
giving birth to her and John's child
this idea was kind of inspired by one of
gray areas videos
she said history may repeat with the
Tower of joy scene we could see this
happen again but instead it's Daenerys
laying in a bed of blood and John is
getting handed his child just as he was
handed to Ned I think that could be a
beautiful scene if that happened in it
mirrored John's birth but I want to take
it a step further and say this could be
the final scene it doesn't have to be in
a better blood or in a tower but I think
the series could end what Daenerys
giving birth and John holding his child
and they could zoom in on the baby's
eyes just like they did with John but it
could zoom all the way into the baby's
eye until it fades to black in the
credits roll I think they made it pretty
clear with all the foreshadowing that
Daenerys would get pregnant even though
she believes she can't since the last
season is only six episodes long she
probably wouldn't have the child until
the very end anyway that would be a
great last scene because it could end
with us knowing that they will have an
heir to follow in their footsteps and
carry the torch for the future
generations another way I could see this
show ending is what the remaining Starks
in Winterfell one of the last scenes in
season six was of John and Sansa
overlooking the battlements in a very
similar scene happened at the end of
season seven also but this time it was
Arya and Sansa overlooking the
battlements season eight could end with
all of the surviving Starks standing up
here reflecting and reminiscing about
everything that they have been through
or talking about Ned or possibly even
what the future may hold for them the
series started in Winterfell and I think
it could end in Winterfell it would only
feel right if the show ends with the
Starks but that's just my opinion if I
were allowed to pick the final scene
there is only one thing I would ask for
and I bet some of you already know it
those of you who have followed my
channel for a while should know one of
the things I am praying to see and I'll
give you a few seconds to guess what
that is
[Music]
I need to see the Starks ancestral
Valyrian steel sword put back together
and placed in the hands of its rightful
owners before the credits roll when
Tywin Lannister had this sword melted
down and reforged it was such a powerful
scene in an emotional one for me this
was one of the symbols of House Stark in
their power in the north but watching it
get melted down was absolutely
heartbreaking it was just another
example of the Starks being broken and
defeated when this sword was melted down
it affected me just as much as some of
the other character deaths did I don't
know why but it just did I think I hated
knowing the Lannisters put their dirty
hands on this steel and then had the
nerve to fashion it into their own style
but the rain is almost over and both of
these swords are about to be in the
north at the same time now I know this
is a major wishful thinking but now that
Brienne has one sword and she's guarding
Sansa and Jaime has the other sword and
he's heading in this direction I think
there is a very good chance the Starks
could end up in possession of their
Valyrian steel again after the wars are
over I know two swords are better than
one but once the army of the Dead are
defeated then they could hopefully
restore ice to its former glory and as
the sword is being placed on a mantel
above the fireplace the camera can zoom
out and fade the black that would be
very powerful in my opinion let me show
you some thoughts some other people had
about the ending then I will get out of
here and start working on a different
video I asked my patreon supporters what
they thought the final scene could be
and this is what some of them had to say
Kendrick said I think it will end where
it began I'm not entirely sure who it
will be but I think it will end with
someone looking out over the wall
my guess is of Stark while they are
rebuilding it Steve said from all your
predictions of who will be left I think
we will see John flying on a dragon
after visiting each of the castles and
new rulers and ending up in Winterfell
with all the remaining Starks that have
feast with ghosts at his feet in John
holding his new son giving a last
longing look at something that reminds
him of Dany
now this next one I'm about to read does
have a potential spoiler in it so please
proceed with caution if you do not want
to know
any possible spoilers kaseylee says i
think it'll be everyone going their
separate ways
I love the leaked video where the last
shot is John with baby lianna and
playing her a song on Ray gars harp I'd
love to see that but I would be confused
where he suddenly gained harp playing
skills though I guess it is in his blood
those are some very interesting ideas
that are just as likely to happen as
anything I probably said I want to thank
those of you on patreon who left me some
of your input and I want to thank
everyone for stopping by to watch
today's video I always appreciate that
and last but certainly not least thank
you to all my patreon supporters I love
you all I hope you have a great day
I'll see you in the next one bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you